in this video we're going to talk about
writing a polinomial function with
rational coefficients and the given
zeros but before we do that the first
thing we want to talk about is this
irrational conjugates theorem what this
tells us is that if our polinomial just
has rational coefficients now remember
rational means like a ratio of an
integer divided by an integer we don't
have any irrational coefficients like
Square < TK of 7 or squ of three
something that can't be WR written as an
integer over an integer then what
happens if if you have an irrational
zero then you're also going to have its
conjugate so for example if I had 3 +
the sare of two as a zero then I also
have 3 minus > two so for this first
example we've got -4 as a0 3 +2 is a
zero so we also know that
3-2 has to be a zero we have to have
that conjugate pair now notice we're
just changing the sign in between these
two terms so if this was minus this
would be plus okay now we know that
these are our zeros and there's a
connection between the zeros and what we
call the factors of the polinomial the
factors are always going to be x minus
the zero so this is like x - -4 which is
like x + 4 x - 3 + < tk2 and x
- uh 3 - <
tk2 now what exactly is a zero well a
zero we know is an X intercept and the
reason they call it a zero is because
the y coordinate is zero you're not
going up or down you're right on that x
axis so that's the key now all we have
to do is multiply this out this is the
more challenging part of the problem but
I'm going to show you some tips to make
it a little bit easier first we're going
to distribute this negative into the
parentheses so that's going to give us x
- 3 minus > 2 distribute this negative
into the parentheses x - 3 +2 I'll have
another example that you can uh you can
do on your own after this if you want to
practice then what we're going to do is
we're going to group these xus 3s
together like so and what this gives us
it gives us a sum and difference pattern
we've got xus 3 we've got square of two
but one we're subtracting one we're
adding what's interesting if you know
how to work with a difference of two
squares like for example a squ minus b^
2 you'll know that this is factors to a
+ b * a minus B and the reason this
works is because a * B and negative a *
B cancel that's why we don't have a
middle term it cancels out right so
similarly over here the inside product
and the outside product are going to
cancel we're just going to end up with x
- 3 * x - 3 which you could write this
as x - 3^ 2 a < tk2 * a postive < tk2 is
-2 a * a positive is a negative2 * S2 is
squ 4 squ of 4 is two but we get a Nega
-2
now the mistake you don't want to make
some students uh just kind of say well
oh this is x^2 + 9 you know they just
Square both of these when you have a
binomial squared you want to think of it
as you've got two of these like x - 3 *
another x - 3 so if you multiply this
out you get
x^2 - 3x minus another 3x + 9 minus this
two here so now if we combine like
terms we get x^2 - 6X + 7 and it's
multiplied by this Factor here x + 4 so
all we have to do now is multiply these
together so let's take x * x^2 that's X
cubed then we have x *
-6x which is -
6x^2 uh x * 7 is 7 x and if we
distribute the four we get
4x^2 4 * -6x is -4x and 4 * 7 is 28 and
all we have to do is add these together
and I'll put the answer over here so
we've got our function which is uh F ofx
equal x
Cub uh -6 x^2 + 4x^2 is -2X
2 okay and then we've got a 7 x - 24x
which
is
17x and plus 28
and that's your polinomial function
notice that the coefficients the numbers
in front of the variables they're
rational like they're they're uh
integers divided by integers so you have
one or -2 -7 square of 20 or 28 you
don't see any square roots like square
of five or Square of 7 those are not in
our polinomial function and the reason
is is because we have these zeros as
conjugate pairs so let's take a look at
another example you can pause the video
and practice this one on your own okay
our zeros are seven and -2 + < tk3 how
would you do this one well if I was
going to do it the first thing that I
would do is recognize that if this is a
Zer -2 + < tk3 -2 -3 would also be a
zero this is what's referred to as the
conjugate pair pair means two conjugate
we're just changing that sign in between
the two terms don't want to make the
mistake of making this plus two it's
just the sign in between that we're
changing to the opposite then we
remember we want to write our factors
which are going to be x minus
are Zer so I say xus thean -2 + <
tk3 and xus the quantity -2 minus < tk3
okay now we're going to distribute the
negative into the
parentheses okay for both of these and
so we're getting x + 2 - > 3 and x + 2 +
> 3 now remember that little trick that
I showed you you can group these X Plus
tws together think of it as like a group
and we've got got a sum and difference
pattern x + 2 is in common the squ of 3
is in common but it's that uh sign in
between okay that's uh different so what
happens is the inner product and the
outer product are going to cancel
because they're the same but one's
positive one's negative and then we get
x + 2 * x + 2 which is x + 2
2ar Okay so let's write that minus 3 * 3
which is just going to give us three
this isquare of 9 which is three Nega *
a positive is a negative remember x + 2^
2 is x + 2 * x + 2 which gives us x^2 +
4x + 4 - 3 if you're not sure write this
twice x + 2 * another x + 2 and
distribute and foil that out so now this
simplifies to x^2 + 4x + 1 and it's
multiplied by this binomial or this
factor x - 7 so we're going to
distribute the X to all three let's see
what does that give give us x cubed +
4x^2 + x and now we're going to
distribute the -7 to each term so -7 x^2
-
28x - 7 and if we combine like terms
here let's write our final answer over
here so our function is going to look
like f ofx = x
cubed 4x^2 - 7 X2 is -
3x^2 1 x - 28x is
27x and we're left with -7 so that's our
polinomial function with rational
coefficients notice we don't have any
irrational coefficients like square of
three or Square of five these are all uh
ratios of integers divided by integers
and you got it so great job I hope
you're able to follow this uh video if
you want to see more examples about
working with polinomial I'll put a video
talking about a similar type of problem
but working with the uh imaginary zeros
or complex zeros follow me over to that
video right there and we'll dive into
that concept I'll see you there